this month the FBI is marking the 100th
anniversary of the hiring of the first
african-american special agent it's a
chapter of the bureau's history that is
not well known but it's relevant to what
is happening inside the FBI today CBS
News chief justice and homeland security
correspondent Jeff Akkad's was given a
rare access to the bureau's archives and
to top FBI officials he's in our
Washington bureau good morning Jeff
good morning Michelle there are no known
photographs of the first African
American special agent but there is a
record of his hiring a century ago and
as we look through the FBI archives
Bureau officials told us that they
believe there are lessons from the past
that are relevant to what is happening
today
inside the FBI inside FBI headquarters
in Washington is an archive room filled
with hundreds of thousands of documents
in this loan application for the job of
special agent it was handwritten in 1919
by James warmly Jones until now the then
35 year old has been a footnote in the
bureau's history and evil is an
assistant director of the FBI
most people don't know who he is that's
true 100 years ago right December of
1919 is when he started he's a son of a
slave Washington Metropolitan Police
officer World War one veteran according
to the FBI Jones was employed
exclusively in an undercover capacity
working directly under J Edgar Hoover
more black agents would follow Jones's
footsteps into the bureau and they too
would work undercover in the black
community Hoover would go on to become
the longest tenured FBI director and
targeting influential black Americans
would become a pattern in the 50s and
60s Hoover targeted Martin Luther King
jr. for extensive surveillance we are
gonna walk non-violently and peacefully
it was actually the
career of a lifetime but that history
did not stop John Glover in 1966 he
became the second african-american
graduate from the FBI's training academy
in Quantico Virginia I had a class of a
new agents training class of 32
individuals I was the only African
American lover would rise through the
ranks and in the late 1970s when the
city of Atlanta was being haunted by a
series of child murders he led the FBI
response I think for the black community
it was kind of satisfying to see an
african-american man up in front in
charge in 1982 Glover would become the
bureau's first black assistant director
still Glover sympathized with other
black agents who sued the FBI alleging
systemic discrimination they would see
themselves in an undercover role or they
would see themselves doing something
that you know only an african-american
agent could do not something that any
agent could do and I there was some
resentment about that was that
resentment valid I think so today less
than 5% of FBI Special Agents are black
a diverse FBI I will be a more effective
FBI Oviatt Morgan of the Los Angeles
field office is the only female African
American special agent in charge I don't
think in the african-american community
you think about oh I want to be an FBI
agent yeah and I hope that changes
I do want little girls that look like me
to have this as a very viable option to
desire it too wanted Andy Vail says
current FBI director Christopher ray has
made recruiting people of color a top
priority in order for us to be
successful I think we need to be
reflective of the communities that were
sworn to protect and serve this month at
the Newseum in Washington the FBI
recognized James worm Lee Jones and
other African American special agents
the Bureau is looking ahead to the
future and acknowledged
it's past we have to own it and we have
to ensure that it doesn't repeat itself
and we have to have everyone in like
mind on that as we move forward new FBI
agents visit the Martin Luther King
memorial in DC and study Hoover's
policies toward King FBI officials say
that it provides a lesson on what
happens when power is abused Jeff Pegues
thank you a fascinating piece an
important piece thanks for coming in
Jeff really eye-opening here that number
less than 5% of FBI agents are
african-american yeah it'd be
interesting to hear how many beyond the
african-american community are now a
part of Bureau how many Asian Americans
Muslim Americans I mean because the net
should be wide I think Chris Rea is
focusing on that right now is Jeff
pointed out there